president Trump celebrated the first
major legislative victory of his
presidency on Friday before heading off
to Florida for the holidays mr. Trump
signed the one and a half trillion
dollar tax overhaul bill into law three
days before the Christmas Day deadline
that Republicans set for themselves
it was his 90 second bill signed into
law during his first year in office the
president is spending the holidays at
his South Florida resort and is hoping
to carry this momentum into his second
year in office chip Reid is in West Palm
Beach chip good morning well good
morning the president rushed signing the
bill without a major ceremony because he
said he wanted to keep his promise to
sign up before Christmas he also signed
a bill to keep the government open for
just one month which guarantees a major
battle over spending in January it's not
fancy but it's the Oval Office
at the last minute president Trump moved
up signing the tax bill originally
scheduled for early January I watched
the news this morning and they were all
saying will he keep his promise will he
sign it by Christmas
you're one but will he sign it by
Christmas and I called downstairs I said
get it ready we have to sign it now
signing a hard-fought bill into law in
what may be the most sweeping tax
overhaul in a generation and assuring
most Americans that they will begin to
see their taxes go down starting in
February most Americans will see their
taxes drop temporarily but the biggest
benefits will go to corporations whose
cuts are permanent the new law also
includes a repeal of Obama cares
individual mandate president Trump later
tweeted the most hated part of Obamacare
is the individual mandate which is being
terminated under our just assigned tax
cut bill a sentiment echoed by Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell I'd love
to see other changes and we're gonna be
moving to bills that have enough votes
to pass next on the president's
legislative agenda infrastructure mr.
Trump believes a bill can get done with
bipartisan support infrastructure is by
far the easiest people wanted
Republicans and Democrats we're gonna
have tremendous Democrat support and
infrastructure as you
I could have started with infrastructure
I actually wanted to save the easy one
for the one down the road so we'll be
having that done pretty quickly but the
president simply cannot pass an
infrastructure bill without Democratic
support and Democrats want to get a deal
on immigration first the president will
meet with congressional leaders in
January when he returns to Washington
discuss legislative priorities for 2018
Anthony chip Reid with the president in
Florida thank you chip